primes stands for program for research in
mathematics engineering and science it's a
free program over the course of a year
working with high school students that
engages them with real research projects
engages them with mit faculty graduate students
who serve as advisors and also they get to
work with their peers who are very high level
what primes is doing is allowing talented
students to enter a mathematical community
allowing them to become part
of a larger academic community
what is a challenge is to increase diversity
this is not only underrepresented minorities
but also women who are severely underrepresented
in mathematics the program provides a pipeline for
talented high school students of color to
enter mit enters the field of mathematics
it hasn't been replicated because it really
requires people like our staff who are very very
dedicated and committed and i want to thank them
and i admire them for their work to be recognized
for such a prestigious award i mean it's it's
mind-blowing and it's very very humbling and and
we're just very appreciative of of this
recognition it's a great honor to to receive this
you